Because I, I love watching artists. Twitter is my favorite. How they.
Artists Twitter is like watching trash TV to me. It's.
Like, you can just go out if you can just grab the.
Popcorn. And it's like watching 90 day fiance or something, you know,
it's like the amount,
the amount of tea that is spilt on like artists, Twitter,
like it's, it's,
it's more T than the Americans threw into the water when they gained
independence, man, my God, I don't know why,
but it's why is it almost always written in lowercase? It's like, it's never,
it's never proper punctuation. They're just like,
let's just make it as low a case as possible, seven, seven tweet thread.
And it's just like, it's,
it's just that you could have summed up into just one time.
Yeah. There's a lot of funny ones. I love it as well when it's like people,
just artists to like, um, giving advice to each other and they're just like,
they all like repeat the same stuff.
And it's always interesting sometimes because they'll be like, yeah,
you should charge people for your art. And I'm like, is this like not known?
Like I should charge people for work. Well,
apparently it's pretty hot. Like, it's pretty common that, I mean,
you see the messages I'm like for exposure, right? For exposures,
a Twitter account. People like ask people that do things for exposure. Yeah.
Which is very funny. And it's true. But an unpopular, you just keep doing work.
That artist should get paid. I wouldn't do an unpopular take. Right.
Don't don't count me for this. But uh, honest, you get paid for that,
to be fair though, Joe called that. But a lot of voice actors,
like where they start out, they'll get like, they'll,
they'll spend all their money on like the new stuff and then they'll be like,
yeah, yeah. I'll, I'll do a commercial for free cause.
Cause people, cause it's, it's different with.
Artists and I think voice actors, cause voice actors,
like you get credits [inaudible] credits.
So it's like a race everyone's just like de-valuing themselves. Cause I like,
yeah, I'll do your, your Kellogg's commercial for $2 and a Kit-Kat ball.
Like let's that's fair that she was good at my name's on the credits side,
right? Yeah. Yeah.
Well I think that there is a balance that should be taken because there is value
in cloud basically. I mean, that's, that's, that's how we make our money. Right.
It's literally, it's literally, we are monetizing clouds. That is,
that is the modern day. We are, we are cloud chasers as an.
Occupant, but like yeah.
No, no, but like I, I get, you know,
artists should definitely be paid and you definitely have a skill set,
but there's, there's also building up your personal branding as well,
which you have to worry about and you know, is it a problem, right?
Is that so many artists starting out?
They don't see themselves as a brand because of that artist mentality. Right?
They're not like, Oh no, I'm just doing it because I like drawing.
I don't want to make this a profession. But then they make,
they make one piece where it's really popular and getting shared everywhere.
And then suddenly they're like, actually I'm a brand. Um, you're stealing.
Yeah. Yeah. Cause I've seen,
I've seen the exact opposite of like talented artists who just don't know how to
charge here,
where you have like an artist who has like two drawings on their portfolio or
something and are charging like ridiculous amounts of money. And it's just like,
come on. There's there, there is balance that that needs to be taken.
Here. Right? Oh yeah. My favorite is when they, like,
I've worked with some artists before and like great. You know, it's all good.
Um, you know, and it's, it's all reasonable. The prices seem fair.
And then I'm like, Oh yeah. It's like for like commercial use or whatever.
And they're like, Oh, Oh, you're like selling it. And then they might like,
they might try and figure, okay, you make this much money.
It's now worth 10,000 for this piece. That's like that. Like what, what do you,
what do you mean? Okay. I'm pretty sure on your website. It said 20 old
looks of industry standard rates. Right. Okay. Well I know Pepsi,
which is basically the Fiverr environment. Right? How,
how was it like working with people and how would you like,
how do you know how much you're worth and it's how to sell it. Right.
Because I think I'm five herds, inherently people like de-value themselves,
but they're all people on Fiverr who are charging like $500 for like $5.
Like honestly, what is like really bad quality. Yeah.
But then the thing is right on fiber, at least I can only speak voice actor.
So I've had a lot of voice actors on Fiverr and like voice actors on Fiverr.
It's like $5 is like, you get a very wide variety of like skill. Yeah.
We, you go all the way from headset. Mine because fiber doesn't,
there's no checks. There's no one on five and being like, yeah,
you seem like a voice actor. You're good to go champ. It's like, Oh,
you have something that, that your PC recognizes as an audio recording device.
You're good to go because it's high, no one heads,
all the white people with worse quality microphone, the Tyler ones screaming,
charging like $20 with commercial rights as an option. And I'm like,
what you want commercial? How do you not know what like a good microphone is,
but you know that you should be charging for commercial. Right?
It's like these two things are like, come on. Like, but then five,
it is like gummy things as well.
Like five a takes cuts from like the tips and five. Uh,
also like I don't like personally that Fiverr makes charges extra for
like higher quality audio files. I just think you should just send a file.
Right?
Like are high quality MPS people just sending MP3s kilobytes can be
putting the wave behind jail or something.
They put like wave files behind paywalls. Sometimes I'm like, why don't do that?
Just give me the world. Why would you not do that?
That's like different between high quality and low quality. It doesn't matter.
But yeah. I didn't know. the, uh,
voice acting industry at DLC now Jesus Christ. That's literally DLC
the Ray tracing voice acting paddle. I'm like, you gotta pay $5 extra.
But this was like, there's people in five are charged, like, you know,
who charge the street rates.
And I don't think Fiverr given the like fiber shouldn't be charging industry
rates in my opinion,
because it's like not really where you should be hiring industry,
shouldn't be hiring on five.
And the ones that do I think should be kind of like, you know,
we won't get into that. Yeah. I never had that experience myself. Um, but yeah,
no, I mean, it's, it's, it's difficult and five voice actors. Uh,
you just listen to that audio. You'll you'll know if works out. It's not.
Just five audios. It's five, it's five, everything, everything, every creative,
uh, job you can think of. Cause it's, I, I, the way I feel,
I feel about Fiverr is that it should be,
it's a good testing ground because you get to such a wide range.
And I feel like it would be a good place to build up your portfolio because from
what I, what I see, like,
it doesn't really matter where you had your education or whatever,
what we've really killed out care about.
Cause w most of the time we are the clients now we're buying the service. Yeah.
We just care about your portfolio. That's the thing that's most.
Yeah, exactly. I'm like show me your work.
Portfolios and also get paid.
Yeah. Yeah. Cause I mean, I used to recommend to voice actors. You know, if you,
if no one's hiring you, you don't know where to start. You know,
don't go to one of these websites that costs like $400 a year to sign up to.
Cause you know, you're not gonna make your money back.
Yeah. Like for example, if we're hiring video, video editors,
like we can get emails about people who are qualified for X, Y, and Z.
But at the end of the day,
we're most likely going to pick people who have worked on anime, anime videos.
Right. Cause we know they have experience working in that field,
like actually know us and like videos and stuff. Exactly.
So it that's, that's the thing it's,
it's more about knowing your target audience and knowing what your
personal branding is.
And it's less important about what you put on your CV because we don't,
we don't really care about CVS that much. Right.
For sure school you went to, is the good or not like it's all there is to it.
There's lots of video editors out there. Right. It's just,
it's just a matter of.
I normally go to like five or somewhere for like,
if I need something like one-off and like fast. Like I just like,
because other times it's a bit of a pain to search. Right.
Have you used Fiverr other than in with like in your files?
Yeah. I've used it, uh, used it for, uh, why do they use it? Uh,
if I need something composed, because I don't know any composers. Right?
Like I'm making music. I go from.
Knowing zero composers to Kevin [inaudible].
Kevin, may I quit? I got this video idea. She's composed me a trip. Like,
so I'll go to someone I'm like,
I'm only like make it like a middy track of this make like a version of that.
But it's normally very basic like thing where I'm like, copy this thing. Yeah.
Um, yeah. I mean,
I think I've had like some emotes on my Twitch stroll in there.
There's a lot of Twitter. There's a lot of Twitch stuff on.
There. There's a lot of artists on Fiverr.
Right? Yeah. But just. Oh my God. There's so many.
Oh, well quote unquote artists. Is that,
is that where you get your Twitch stuff?
Cause I've actually been looking to try and like upgrade my Twitch presentation
because my Twitch presentation is because I've never given the ship about
streaming before.
On Fiverr. It's tailored towards like,
I think what the like general audience of people who are looking to get into
live streaming would once. Right. So it's all like very gamer looking.
You know what I mean? When I say that, right? Like,
like 90% of the Fiverr stuff for like talking to that, like Twitch,
I like Twitch overlays all like something that is an application to the phase
clan. Like it doesn't look like,
I would say the default ones that you get on like stream labs,
which is why I think I ended up hiring someone who I know that did a lot of this
stuff and who watched some of my stuff.
So they were kind of familiar with my mind.
They mine as well.
And I met an artist recently who probably going to get high because yeah.
At the same thing, it was like, Oh,
cause right now I'm using like a default one. Hmm. I'm just like, she probably,
probably personalized it a little more. Make it stand out a little bit.
How'd you how'd you guys find artists, you just DM people on Twitter.
Tweet out or like ask on live streams. I'm like, Hey guys, I need something.
Can someone tell me like where I go?
Because I find through like them doing fan out of me. Okay. Yeah. So like the,
the, uh, the post I'm probably going to be hiring soon as rocket cut,
who did like a bunch of like drawings with me and Chris,
the Jenny cross your pants off. Right. And it's really cute. So I also,
I was like, yo, can you do some Twitch stuff? And she's like, okay. Yeah.
So just asking around, yeah.
I have no idea what artist's worth. So whatever they give me,
if it's not ridiculous, I'm like, it. I'll pay that. Whatever, man,
I'm more comfortable being like, what do you want.
Versus like, I'll give you $15.
It's always a debate. Right. Is it,
is it you as the buyer should ask or should the person like the client say,
Hey, this is what I'm worth because I frustrates me when I hear like,
what's your budget? And I'm like.
I don't have a budget. I just wanna know what the worth, what do you want?
What's your hourly rate?
Are you telling me, like, I don't know.
I understand that that's in place where people who can't maybe afford the other
things, but I'm like, I don't know.
Whatever you think is, well, tell me I'll pay it. It's like,
it's like a standoff. Right? It's like,
you're waiting for the first one to like, say a number. It's just like,
how much, how much is this worth? Like, what's your budget. I hate that debate.
Right. I, I get it there from the artist perspective, because like,
they're probably like, Oh, if I say it's something that's a little too high,
then I'm afraid I might lose the client.
Right. But that's when you can negotiate. Right. You can be like, ah,
I think that's a little, little too high. Or was it maybe something like that?
A lot of them starting off don't know any better.
Afraid at first as well. Like when, you know, I'd get sponsorship opportunities,
that'd be like, what do you want for it? I'm like, ah.
I don't know how much do you have.